L5 "Toutes les femmes de ta vie"
T'es chaud.
2Be3 "Partir un jour"
Yes.
Oh putain ! 2-0
Ah il était dur celui-là.
Après là, j'étais vachement focus aussi sur le... Ouais, ouais...
Tu as dit quoi ? Focus sur quoi ?
Sur la cam.
Sur la cam alors. Maintenant, je vais faire juste...
Le Blind Test mais mes paroles c'est que "focus sur la cam".
Ah ça a l'air pas mal, là.
Là, ça a l'air pas mal...
Là, ça a l'air mal...
Là, ça a l'air pas mal !
Billy Crawford ! Billy Crawford putain !
"Drag on me" là, mes couilles... 3-0
Pour Aurélien.
Tu peux baisser un tout petit peu la clim' ?
Tu peux baisser un petit peu la clim'...
Au fait, elle est au minimum.
Faut que tu baisses là.
Là, là.
C'est...
Eiffel 65 !
Mais j'ai jamais ! J'ai jamais les artistes !
Tu as déjà utilisé ton extincteur ? Jamais.
Tu as utilisé ton extincteur... "Le temps des cathédrales" !
Non !
Garou !
Garou et la chanson... "Celui qui n'a jamais été seul" !
Ça fait 5-1... Moi souvent j'ai pas les titres mais j'ai les visages...
Si je décris les visages et les vêtements ?
Déjà on te donne 1 point alors que...
On met la ceinture !
Tu mets pas ta ceinture, mec ?!
Lui non plus, derrière ?!
Les gars, je paie tout et après on calculera sur... Non, non c'est bon !
On calculera sur le... Te prends pas la tête, paie tout et c'est tout.
Te prends pas la tête, paie tout et c'est tout...
"Mamakusa" !
Michael Jackson, Rihanna ?
Te prends pas la tête, paie... mais non !
Ah je suis pas d'accord ! Si.
T'aurais dû faire...
Te prends pas la tête, paie tout et c'est tout...
Bah écoutes ! J'ai reconnu, j'ai reconnu...
C'est ce que j'ai fait. Te prends pas la tête, paie tout et c'est tout.
Ah je suis déçu.
Il a dû avoir le seum.
Il a dû avoir le seum...
Maître Gims ? Putain !
T'es vraiment naze.
Il y a 8-1
Jamais, il y en a même pas eu 9.
Bah il y avait 5-1 quand t'as trouvé un interprète
Tu crois qu'il y a 8-1, vraiment ?
Il y a 5-5.
Non, il y a 5-3.
Non, 5-5. 5-3, vas-y, ça relance.
Vas-y, 5-3.
Mon ongle, ça part totalement en couille, ouais...
On peut dire moche, quoi...
On peut dire moche, on... on peut dire moche...
Axelle Red "Sensualité".
Par contre, là, je vais vraiment faire une micro sieste...
Mais non, tu conduis.
Mais non, tu conduis, mais non, mais non, mais tu conduis mais non mais non... Celui-là je te le laisse !
"Les rois du monde"
8-4.
C'est faisable, c'est remontable.
C'est faisable, c'est remontable... C'est faisable ! C'est faisable, c'est remontable...
C'est vraiment de l'impro, là !
Britney Spears !
Putain !
"Baby, hit me one more time" L'impro...
C'est celle que j'ai le mieux fait, là !
C'est faisable et remontable !
C'est faisable !
Si on dit que "faisable et remontable" il va pas pouvoir faire une autre chanson...
Il va repartir sur la même...
Il va repartir sur la même, repartir. Il va repartir sur la même, repartir...
Shaggy !
Oui !
9-5.
Et si tu cites une ville du 9-5 dans les 5 secondes, Freddy, tu gagnes un autre point.
Cergy Pontoise ! Yes !
Oui !
Après moi, je suis aussi très focus sur la conduite, tu vois...
Du coup... Ouais, ouais, ouais...
Faut faire gaffe aussi...
Moi je suis... très focus... sur la conduite... y'a ce truc... où je dois faire gaffe... y'a ce truc... où... je dois faire gaffe...
Après... moi je suis très... Allô !
Sur la conduite... Nouma noumaye !
O... O-zone !
Freddy remonte, attention...
Ouais mais j'attends, moi. Je veux une finale à 9-9.
J'ai pas vu sur le GPS...
Il m'a pas indiqué...
Il m'a pas indiqué, j'ai pas vu sur le GPS... J'ai pas vu sur le GPS... J'ai pas vu sur le GPS...
Tout sonne R&B avec Anis...
Putain...
Il est trop beau ce moment... "I need a one dance" ?
9-8, mon gars !
Mais t'inquiètes, moi, je suis chaud.
Après, c'est 2 points d'écart, hein ?
Après... après c'est 2 points d'écart...
Gilbert Montagné !
Oh merde, il y a 9-9.
C'est "Sous le sunlight des tropiques"
9-9 !